hello sorry and welcome
to this video playing black against
sarah connor okay
without an h
so that's not the character from
terminator
or the the german singer anyway
i got the dirty harry on the board
the opening line that i recently
published a chestable course on the h5
sicilian and bishop g5 is one of the
more frequently played moves
i had this on the board quite frequently
and also this i had this on the board a
lot
so black is okay here it's a complicated
position
this mistake is made very often people
don't appreciate that there is bishop h6
and here um i i also had this on the
board so this is like
opening theory for me but not for the
opponent
knight before is interesting e6 also a
good move but
this is more um yeah aggressive let's
say
um
can play many things d6 e6 a6
let's go d6
h3 okay
it's not so nice for the pawn structure
so let's go directly to rook g8 here
threatening bishop takes h3
let's see how we play this a couple of
interesting options
maybe bishop out to e6
okay c8
let's just complete development and then
see what to do next
i also have the idea to take on d3 and
play f5 that
looks very attractive as well
but yeah so
it's a very convenient position anyway
uh what so
wants to take with i mean he wants us he
takes with a rook now that's what i'm
trying to say
not very successfully
um okay
there's no immediate tactical win right
i mean the position looks
shaky that white has
i'm just doubling against the g pawn
what are you doing there how do you
cover the g pawn now
f3 i take h3 okay it doesn't cover it so
i just take it now what is the what is
the big idea
oh i'll take it
this is three plus two by the way
should always be be noted um
okay this is winning
rook takes is made and this is also
going to be made
rook h2
yeah the mate coming up
so let's let's have a look there yeah
this is the dirty harry sicilian
uh i will make a video on my channel
also
shortly maybe today tomorrow or
something like that where i'm going to
introduce that a little bit and
um there's currently the the course is
still fresh on chessable so it's on sale
if you're interested the move has
multiple
ideas and here we see one of the ideas
and that is that you sometimes get in a
quick bishop h6
in this particular case um white was
completely stumbling into that queen d2
is not a good idea
white should probably castle after which
the situation is just
pretty unclear you see that the engine
here gives white a small advantage
which is i don't know maybe fair but the
position is so murky that it's difficult
to assess this is however a common
mistake
and here you have many good ideas but
night before is
that is what i came up with when i
analyzed this
um maybe near not precisely this
position
but yeah it could be this position i
don't know
this is however a pretty good structure
so and i have multiple ideas h3 is
strategically dubious because
you just make the g2 pawn
a liability for the rest of the game
maybe he was so worried about me playing
h3 i don't know
this is in any case good for black
and i have multiple options
so king d7 i just wanted to connect the
rooks
and now he played a3 i don't know
it's really really good for black f5 is
good but doubling is also
it seems like fine and this is just
completely ignoring everything bishop c4
is also possible i just see that
but um yeah
knight d2 is better
everybody this is good right because now
f3
actually i can take a i can take him as
i wanted to do
got this
idea and yeah it's just it's just over
knight c5 however i overlooked that
i overlooked that actually
i can take here so i'm still winning but
i
i didn't see that this move is possible
at all
yeah okay the way it wait happened
um i'm just i'm just checkmating
yeah bishop g5 is frequently played and
an
interesting test of h5 i'm not sure that
it's the best move
probably not but it's um at least a
testing and very frequently scene move
okay thanks for watching